[Music]
please state your name for the record
Daniel Ocean Oh credit oh wait oops
guess I jumped the gun there a bit I
mean the spirit of the sin is still
covered by this movie moment technically
premature celebration on my part you
might say the purpose of this hearing is
to determine whether if released you are
likely to break the law again George
Clooney begins the movie by being
paroled and immediately hatches a
criminal plan click shit also I know
this is a prison and all but is this
room is there a law that mandates they
hold these hearings and what looks like
a set from the Saw franchise well this
was your first conviction you have been
implicated though never charged and over
a dozen other confidence schemes and
frogs experts position is it likely to
fall back into a similar pattern she
already left me once I don't think she'd
do it again just for kicks look the only
reason Danny's getting paroled here is
because he's George Clooney not only did
he not answer the question this is a
pretty dickish thing to say to a parole
board I mean even red had a better
rapport in Shawshank Clooney is the only
DC film star here marble is represented
out the ass Topher Grace from spider-man
3 Don Cheadle from the MCU Matt Damon
from thor ragnarok Brad Pitt from the
movie I'm not comfortable naming just
yet given the date of this video's
release but for DC just cloning here
Marvel is even winning the oceans
casting wars are you saying Oh Frank
why doesn't Frank recognize Danny until
he calls him by name not only does he
know who he is he knows his entire
situation
Shane unless I heard he was teaching
movie stars how to play cards Danny and
Frank played the pronoun game for some
reason even though we know this movies
already going on way too long without
Brad pity
no sir I wouldn't even think about
leaving the state and the rest of the
movie will happen without a single
parole officer calling or showing up to
ask questions and thus begins the
annoying habit of rusty eating and or
drinking something in nearly every scene
he's in seriously
that motherfucker should be 300 pounds
by the end of this movie this teaching
Hollywood peeps how to poker scene is
hilariously dated he's teaching Topher
Grace Shane West the least famous
Charmed girl 7-7 guy and Joshua Jackson
maybe just maybe your references would
have lasted longer if he'd chosen film
actors instead of TV actors or just
avoided the goddamn WB's early TV slate
also Topher Grace in a movie with too
many villains movie sucks Topher Grace
in a movie with too many honks works
every time
you can't have three pairs you can't
have six cards in a five card game yeah
but that's pretty much on rusty here he
didn't notice the misdeal but gave Shane
the extra card given how clueless these
assholes are sure does seem like Rusty's
a teacher I will see you on five hundred
and I will raise you another five
hundred string betting Holly this
opening Hollywood bull goes on for way
too long
New York's hottest club is deep its
keyhole logo icon is only half the
unlockable treasure waiting within this
hot spot that merges lust danger and
ambivalence also the fuck's up with club
boob back there sounds like a much
better place for a poker tutorial this
little gag about Topher Grace being
swarmed by fans as Brad Pitt and George
Clooney casually walked by has always
made me giggle
once it off wanna knock over to see I
know they're tucked away in a booth but
there are people around them in this
restaurant they could have talked about
this extremely illegal plan in the car
or even in the parking lot safely out of
earshot Boesky a Jim Brown a Miss Daisy
to Jethro's and Leon Spinks not to
mention the biggest Ella Fitzgerald
ever whoa that's racist honestly I'm not
sure so I guess I'll send this
ridiculous heist e-code speak that
sprinkled in all these movies
hey Oscar lower the bed would you
sorry what Oscar should be sorry about
is using a flashlight to cause the first
of many unnecessary fake outs in this
brightly lit room Jesus the level of
handsome in this movie is off the charts
you'd think it'd be enough to remove us
in but this movie is too handsome you
know the three most successful robberies
in the history of Vegas they most
assuredly do no this but will be treated
with an expositional flashback just to
bring this point home and the closest
any man has ever come to robbing a Las
Vegas casino seriously the most
successful attempts at biggest robbery
have involved people running through the
casino with huge amounts of cash in
plain sight
just out of curiosity which casinos did
you geniuses Victor ah wait hold up the
actual casinos in question weren't
revealed when they told him the plan
that's bad enough on its own but when
you factor in that this guy hates the
dude that owns the three casinos they
eventually named it's even worse in real
life these fools would have started with
Terry Benedict sucks some now in
crafting this all-star cast for the
casino heist reboot film they still
ended up with Casey Affleck and Scott
Caan in this movie proving that the
power of nepotism still beats the power
of most anything else in Hollywood
Brothers hours nerves okay not so bad
you notice the way this old-timey phrase
is shoehorned into Rusty's dialogue I'm
expecting the rest of his lines to be
peppered with a few 23 skidoo 'he's at
least a couple of horse feathers and one
hang Langille go find great stone my
needs soon oh just find him well yeah of
all the times I could say this works in
this movie this is that this works hist
badger know for sure that no one was
going to be in that car or is he okay
with casual homicide sir okay which
one's the amazing young the little
Chinese guy that's racist the director
said let's have you carve up an orange
in the scene so that you can be unique
and edgy but still not so much of an
asshole that the viewers can't relate to
you are you gonna treat me like a
grown-up at least tell me what the scam
is
dog track races are not this loud
especially since we heard everything
they said up until now quite clearly you
want to keep me in the dark just been
cut away
Jesus you dick anything we need one more
do you think we need one more yeah but
that one more is Matt Damon it was
apparently the best thief on the planet
right this is phrased as an afterthought
but he would have been a huge part of
the plan from the beginning in case you
confused it with Chicago California I
don't doubt that Will Hunting is a great
thief but what kind of jagoff keeps his
wallet in this location on a crowded
train despite being super thief Matt
Damon super thief Matt Damon doesn't
notice the obvious theft from his own
pocket this pair has had this printed
for years and keeps it in a safety
deposit box or some there's no way he's
had time to get them printed since
leaving jail and you're pretty trusting
pretty fast could get the check please
that's the best lift I've seen you make
yet you mean even better than that super
quick theft of the wallet on the train
he looked away from the table and even
lifted his fucking hand this movie has
entirely too much drone footage porn
what did you guys get a group rate or
something but no seriously did you this
is a great question considering that
even though they're coming from all over
the country these assholes arrive at
exactly the same time gentlemen the 3000
block of Las Vegas Boulevard otherwise
known as the Bellagio the Mirage and the
MGM Grand for a movie specifically about
Las Vegas this is really obscuring the
geography not only are all three of
these casinos actually separated by
several other casinos they're not really
on the same block it's like saying the
Upper West Side of Manhattan otherwise
known as Central Park and the Dakota
this place houses a security system that
rivals most nuclear missile silos this
says more about missile silos than it
does this casino yeah
Wow that don't don't you know tunneling
is out there sensors monitoring the
ground 100 yards in every direction
I'll buy that rusty is able to
understand Chinese but how does yen
understand him perfectly when he speaks
English only once during the movie okay
Ruben's already been set up as a legend
as a character do we really need this
shot of him in real life smoking while
standing next to the frame Time magazine
cover portrait of him smoking you'd
probably be less conspicuous with a cart
that had the word inconspicuous written
all over it this is Las Vegas what Las
Vegas strip club has tape crosses
covering the nipples and who goes to
them thanks aw man tie your mom for me
our horror movie but we just saw Frank
spying on the dude that's in love with
Charmaine and having to write it down so
how does rusty know her mom computer
nerd genius God guy is so stupid
he can't remember a simple path without
a map drawn on his hand also this hand
map situation turns out to be a big deal
when Livingston is leaving but he was
just wearing gloves right it should have
already sweat it off why didn't he draw
this on the glove this extended chasing
down a guy and it seemed to fair yes but
it's actually innocent because he's only
returning something he lost and isn't
the killer was done much better in
Joyride which came out three months
before this I might adopt that down to
say 7/16 each Frank literally strong
arms this poor bastard into taking 2,500
off of each BAM
even though the oceans crew could surely
afford them remind me why we're rooting
for these guys again it's imported silk
sauce man but the ringleader of this
operation Danny sure does sit around
doing Jeff a lot during the first half
of this movie this fictional foreign
better shtick includes matrix agent such
as bad carriers and it's definitely fun
to laugh at them in this getup smiley
emoji what do they talk about all
business but he just asked about Frank's
family
Jesus this movie contradicts the doubt
of itself he's scared he's suicidal
sounds like Linus needs his security
blanket comes a girl where she come from
Museum if there's a curator I'm
reasonably sure that no matter your
references you can never get a job as an
art gallery curator if you've previously
dated a known incarcerated or thief this
is the best part of my day expositional
upskirting I say I'm even caught a name
Tess - knows everything about Terry at
this point and knows the test is the
museum curator but he didn't catch her
name just so we can have this reveal in
recreating Andy Garcia's underground
vault these guys decided that meant a
chip for a chip which is a level of
realism even quitting Tarantino would
spit on the face of wait they're
building this mock-up right across the
street from the Bellagio and the door is
wide open how would they not had someone
wander in here even by accident
and remember test is not split 11 ways I
mean isn't it just a matter of deciding
who goes first everything goes to plan
so wait you've conveniently drew up a
plan ahead of time that involved ocean
getting fake arrested and faked beat up
by a dude on his payroll before anyone
found out the casino owner is currently
fuckin oceans ex-wife do I have that
right because that is literally the
least believable thing in this movie
which is saying a hell of a lot you like
it I like that you like honestly if I
were her this would be a relationship
ender
this is the kind of answer given by a
boyfriend who thinks his job is to
compliment his lady as opposed to a
boyfriend that is just being honest and
happening to often agree with and
compliment the lady as an offshoot of
that when you two meet up tonight like
is it a secret that they're dating also
I hasn't she dumped him yet is she
waiting for someone to rob him and jolt
her into realizing he's a terrible
douche nozzle of a boyfriend he owns all
this but he won't kiss her because some
jabroni watching a security monitor
might see it here's the scene where
Danny reveals himself to test because he
needs her casino owning boyfriend to get
suspicious and have him citizen arrested
later during the climax which was part
of the plan before anyone found out Tess
was even here which makes this a paradox
worse than the whole of the movie looper
now they tell me that I paid my debt to
society funny I never got a check only
sometimes the dialogue really threatens
to outsmart itself in this movie who the
hell talks like this I had to leave New
York to get away from what happened even
more reason why your high profile
employment here in Las Vegas is so
shocking
do you mind what I said to you when we
first met you said that I better know
what I'm doing so many questions here
was that the only thing she said to him
when they met why would she even say
this unless they light went tandem
skydiving or something who says that to
someone they just met why the hell is
the dialogue and the scene so goddamn
clunky jeez it's like Terry gets his
entire wardrobe directly handed down
from Disney Villains the shot of Clooney
and Damon being the only ones not to
turn around a look at the building
implosion is awesome Steven Soderbergh
doesn't have a
batting average but when he's on his
game it's badass they've only nosed up
the mainframe couplet nosed it right up
I guess Don Cheadle heard this was an
ensemble piece and figured it was a Guy
Ritchie movie I have no other
explanation for this abominable accent
we could use a pinch
this guy just slogged all the way here
drenched in sewage to tell the gang the
problem and then immediately comes up
with a solution
he's like a deus ex machina how does a
facility holding the world's largest EMP
bomb not have any gate security it's
less guarded than the neighborhood
Bieber lives in number no reason at all
Danny decides to stiff-arm Matt Damon's
character a guy he flew all the way to
goddamn Chicago to recruit for this
mission because he suddenly needs
someone to treat like an intern or
something but really it's just so Damon
could disobey here create a minor action
moment and so more fake dissension
between them that is here only to serve
that whole inexplicable no one on the
team knows Danny's arrest his fateful
late here's where you have to blame
Damon's character though because even if
he had to leave the van to escape the
brothers annoying and he did he still
could have just gotten out and stood
there outside the van he didn't have to
run into the building three minutes late
to the heist any idea how this happened
oh come on he's been chasing Benedict's
girl Hulk about to rage this is not your
call when you put her before us you made
it mine this is all an act and I'm just
gonna tack on 15 sins to this movie for
this overly complicated I'm not even
sure it was ultimately needed Danny
loves Tess Roos even though she's an art
curator I still feel like this film
represents the saddest possible outcome
for the gal Julia played and pretty
woman what are you thinking about you
man this movie wastes its only female
character so hard that it spawned a
whole unnecessary gender swap to reboot
don't touch your time look at me if
you're this nervous about his ability to
do the role just don't let Danny
confront Tess and the restaurant earlier
in the movie I was on purpose and
everyone knows it so this can the
replacement guy handle it both that's
just a waste of time
and for God's sake whatever you do don't
under any circumstance
despite Rusty not and parting the most
important bit of advice he could give
Linus his performance goes off without a
hitch sure I bet the fights gonna be
exciting but it's nothing compared to
that upcoming Rick Springfield Show
movie goes full Donnie Brasco here and
has no shame about it that's not please
sure even though I know you as an arms
dealer and those stones are possible
explosives I feel like this hands only
wiped down as sufficient for something
that's going in my precious vault that's
also holding 160 million dollars why
does the EMP device run on mountain
or is that mello Yello you ready what
the hell is this super Ghazi both bandit
if he ends hand is broken from the van
door collision then he should have some
sort of brace at least ace bandage that
this stuff is guaranteed to be caught up
in the vault door mr. Benedict hi
Sheldon Willis Nevada Gaming Commission
even more anger builds up inside me as I
realized the role they are claiming was
originally Clooney's but Damon is
last-minute filling in for directly
interacts with Benedict who would
definitely know Danny ocean on sight
Christ the whole Danny recognized
arrested replace whatever she flimsy and
needs to be publicly flogged and no one
ever found these empty uniforms or
reported them to anyone be it mr. ocean
mr. Benedict would like to see you these
thugs have been following Danny since
the slot area but only stepped in to
grab him after he's publicly manhandled
and kissed Harry's girlfriend you
definitely let me deal two cars might as
well call it white jack
god I miss Bernie Mac see pickpocketing
is tough to show on film since it should
be invisible but a movie has to slow
that down so you can realize you're
watching a pickpocket but still this is
too obvious for me not to send it next
time just the card why didn't they have
the card again this plan has everything
at every moment except right here with
this one car don't ever do what you did
tonight again but other than that
rebuked I'm probably not serious enough
to follow up on any of this in fact
you'll be back in your room in my hotel
in a matter of minutes do these guys
seriously need to outsource their muscle
and how did Danny know Terry would
specifically get mr. clean to beat his
ass not until late even though the guys
outside will easily hear bruised or fake
fight Danny later on they don't hear
anything set here this is ultimately the
movies explanation for all the fury
regarding who knew Danny was going to be
arrested and who didn't and it's
unsatisfactory as hell James Bond much
movie that stars Batman and born they
made it the joy I feel in my heart
almost makes me forget that the drop
lines are still dangling from above and
would surely be setting off the sensors
that are back online now ah I didn't
realize that boxers were thought to
immediately abandon their training in
the case of a power failure and start
flailing madly at their opponents when
the lights come back on the lights were
off for 30 seconds right I know humans
are awful but would they start
immediately rioting even when the power
was restored thankfully not Batman
George Clooney
somehow still has access to hockey puck
knockout bombs even though he gasps
strong enough to knock two grown men out
was just deployed two other grown men
are about to walk into its proximity
with no effects this has all been too
easy I think we need to saddle the
heroes with a last-minute weird delay
event you bet
what's yen so angry about again did he
want them to blow the door around
earlier and kill him other than that
they're exactly on schedule it's almost
like the script one of this little
Chinese do to save gonna win from their
2018 hipster doom and a Bellagio must be
much smaller than I remember
since test finds rusty immediately after
leaving the Monitor room also all those
riots at the tables I guess they just
resolved themselves I mean deep down
people are good where's Danny and he's
fine he's in good form you requested you
go upstairs and watch TV he asked that
because he set up a whammy of a TV show
to prove to her that Andy Garcia is a
dickhole but she shouldn't need video
proof of that and everyone knows it and
it's the worst kept secret in this movie
cutting power even though this is dummy
footage that was shot yesterday it
perfectly syncs up to Terry cutting the
power at the hotel it's magic I tells
you tires tires oh sure the one time the
bad guys actually aim at the tires the
Vans not even moving
also casual gunfire and an extremely
busy airport is extremely casual yep all
those flyers for hookers that were
somehow already hanging out in the
Bellagio vault alongside the 160 million
even though there's no way that they
could have made it into those bags
[Music]
holy did they intercept and divert all
the 911 calls during this timeframe they
probably just killed a lot of Vegas turn
to channel 88 who is this Jesus I think
Tessa's only character trait is do
whatever the men tell you to do
I'll find out he took your money you
know our guy show mr. Ocean the exit
after being positive that Danny had a
role in this robbery teri immediately
dismisses his offer for help because
plop how long will you be well let's
wait and see what the box office does on
this one
look I like the scene and I love the
music that takes so long it may as well
have been directed by Peter Jackson it's
adopted picked up the personal effects
hope you don't mind
holy now the movies openly referring to
test this fucking property fine gender
swap the reboot this movies definitely
earned it you think we need one more do
you think we and in my club I will
splish the port whenever the fuck I
please don't say anything yet I don't
think it works for somebody else Gary so
last where they know about anything this
is your game I've never played before
I'm not a game not something you play
well does this make any sense to you I
don't have to
what's a pinch punch punch up pinch well
I said bench mean I learned my lesson I
can honestly say it it will change man
please no gang ties no throw it up on
him it looks like a giant dick hey
George the ocean call they're running
out of shrimp my new